[Music]
do you think we'll make it
not without my team we'd do this
together
[Music]
it all happened so fast
there was a solar flare
goodbye crops and food goodbye
everything
[Music]
so i
frightened and so alone
and i found you
[Music]
where should we have
get your elbows off the tube keep your
elbows up
all right you're next
you see i'm developing something
interesting
giant leap of faith
now if you can speak
tell me something
about you but the robots must protect
dog
if we don't go before that storm hits
we'll die all of us as soon as you can
walk we're leaving one two
[Music]
head west over the moons would you like
me to drive
don't over steer
that's over here
use your foot up just a hair perfect
[Music]
hey what's on the fuss i learned to talk
dog
i don't think it likes me
come and see this
hang on to something
we should be safe once we get into the
mountains those things will happen
like a 150 degree heat
uv radiation
and people
hiding in the shadows
do you think we'll make it
not without my teeth
what we do
we do together
i believe in you things
[Music]
[Music]
you